Good afternoon, everybody. I'm Jos Jonkers, a group leader at the Netherlands
Cancer Institute.
I hope that everyone is enjoying this very exciting AACR Annual
Meeting. I had the great honor and privilege of serving as chair
of this year's selection committee for the Paz Scholar Foundation AACR
International Award for Extraordinary Achievement in Cancer Research.
Before we begin with the award presentation and lecture, I would first
like to invite the president of the Paz Scholar Foundation, Dr.
Enzo Galligioni, to come forward and make a few
remarks.
Mr. Chairman, ladies and gentlemen, thank you
for this opportunity to present the Paz Scholar Foundation
to you today. Its activities are summarized in the
following short video.
No, I think
I was wrong. Maybe somebody can help me
for the video.
I think I need help.
Okay.
Continuous and blasting progress in cancer science
have greatly improved treatments and chances of cure.
Now more than ever, it is necessary to support cancer
research, and that is the mission of the Paz Scholar
Foundation. Established in 1980 in Trento,
Italy, by Professor Alessio Paz Scholar.
The Paz Scholar Foundation pursues its aims through
awards, education, and support to young
researchers. Through the award to outstanding cancer
researchers in collaboration with the American Association for
Cancer Research, the foundation emphasizes the
extraordinary achievements that increased biological
knowledge and improved cancer prevention and
therapy.
It has been conferred to the most deserving scientists in the
world.
Remarkably, four of them have been subsequently awarded with a
Nobel Prize for the same reasons.
In collaboration with the European Association for Cancer Research,
the Paz Scholar Foundation rewards young and
outstanding European scientists in the field of translational
cancer research. And more recently, scientists
who fostered the advancements of women in cancer research.
And very promising early career scientists in partnership
with the Mark Foundation.
Through the Paz Scholar Symposia, a series of impactful and
visionary meetings since 1988, the Paz Scholar
Foundation promotes debates on cutting-edge
topics among leading international experts,
and the scientific growth and interaction of young researchers,
also favored by poster presentations, scientific lectures,
and seminars.
Moreover, the Paz Scholar Foundation supports several
research grants and fellowships for young scientists at the
international,
national,
and local level.
Providing researchers with more opportunities to pursue their
projects and share their results with the cancer research
community.
The Paz Scholar Foundation is committed to reward excellence in
cancer research and support young scientists
in collaboration with the main scientific societies.
For the benefit of all of us.
So
this is the Paz Scholar Foundation, which has
collaborated with the AACR for this
prestigious award since 1997,
and we are extremely proud and grateful
for this 29-year partnership,
which has enabled us to identify and
reward the world's best cancer
researchers.
Four of them have gone on to win the Nobel Prize,
which clearly demonstrates the rigor of our
selection process and the excellence of our winners.
This year is particularly significant
because, for the first time, we have two winners,
who equally contributed to one of the most
important achievements in the fight against cancer.
The anti-HPV vaccine, which has already
saved hundreds of thousands of lives around the
world. And today, I have the privilege of
presenting the recipients of the 2026 Paz
Scholar Foundation AACR International
Award for Extraordinary Achievement in Cancer
Research, Dr. Douglas Lowy and Dr.
John Schiller from the National Cancer Institute in Bethesda.
Congratulations, Dr. Lowy and Dr. Schiller.
Thank you, Dr. Gallicioni.
It's a great honor for the AACR to share such a special
partnership with the Pescola Foundation for the purpose of recognizing
scientific excellence.
In addition to Dr. Gallicioni, I would like to thank the other members of the
Pescola Foundation delegation who've traveled from Italy to be
with us today, including Dr. Mascia French.
We greatly appreciate your unwavering support in administering this award and
applaud the Pescola Foundation's dedication to recognizing
exceptional scientific achievement each year.
The AACR is proud to collaborate with the foundation in honoring these
extraordinary contributions to cancer research.
The Pescola Foundation AACR International Award for Extraordinary
Achievement in Cancer Research was first established in
1997.
This award celebrates scientists whose discoveries have had a transformative
impact in basic or translational cancer research.
Eligible recipients must remain actively engaged in cancer research,
produce recent high-impact publications, and continue
work that advances the field in meaningful ways.
This year, we're honored to recognize two extraordinary
scientists whose work has fundamentally transformed cancer
prevention worldwide.
Doctors Douglas R. Lowy and John T.
Schiller are internationally renowned for their groundbreaking research
on human papillomavirus, HPV,
which led to the development of the first vaccine specifically designed to
prevent cancer.
Their collaboration over the past three decades has directly
prevented tens of thousands of HPV-related cancers each year,
including cervical, anal, vulvar, vaginal, penile, and
oropharyngeal cancers. These vaccines are now FDA
approved and used worldwide with broad global access through
multiple manufacturers.
Doctors Lowy and Schiller made two pivotal discoveries
enabling the HPV vaccine.
First, they found that the viral L1 protein can
self-assemble into non-infectious virus-like particles,
VLPs, capable of triggering strong neutralizing
antibodies.
Second, they showed that small variations in L1 sequence
affect particle assembly as well as immunogenicity.
On the base of this knowledge, they developed preclinical models, serological
assays, and mechanistic studies that established the vaccine's efficacy,
safety, and durability.
Their work also demonstrated that VLPs can generate tissue-resident
T-cells and informed therapeutic strategies, including
VLP-based cancer immunotherapies now under clinical
investigation.
Clinical efficacy trials of multivalent HPV vaccines
conducted by five commercial manufacturers in collaboration with the National
Cancer Institute have shown these vaccines provide near complete
protection against cervical, anal, vulvar, and vaginal dysplasias, as
well as genital warts caused by the targeted HPV types.
Doctors Lowy and Schiller were instrumental in launching the first
NIH-sponsored trials and continue to play an active role in
analyzing trial data and overseeing long-term follow-up,
ensuring the vaccine's effectiveness and safety are maintained as they are
delivered to millions of people worldwide.
More recently, Doctors Lowy and Schiller have extended their discoveries beyond
prevention to new therapeutic applications.
They showed that HPV pseudovirions
transferring viral target genes can induce protective tissue-resident
T-cells following intravaginal vaccination in preclinical models of
genital HPV infection and neoplasia.
They also identified a broad and specific tumor-binding tropism of the
HPV VLPs and leveraged this property to develop novel
cancer therapeutics based on VLP infrared dye
conjugates.
This innovative therapy is currently being evaluated in a phase three trial for
ocular melanoma and a phase one trial for bladder cancer,
underscoring the ongoing translational impact of their work.
The efforts of Dr. Lowy and Dr. Schiller have had an extraordinary and
resounding impact on public health.
In regions with widespread vaccination, cervical cancer rates
among young women have declined dramatically.
Their innovative one-dose vaccine strategy also holds
promise for expanding access into low-resource settings, where
HPV-related mortality remains highest.
Doctors Lowy and Schiller's contributions have been recognized with numerous
prestigious awards, including the Albert Sabin Gold Medal
Award, the Research and Hope Award from the Pharmaceutical Research and
Manufacturers of America, the National Medal of Technology and
Innovation, the Lasker, the Bakeries Clinical Medical
Research Award, and the Sant'Jorgini Prize for
Progress in Cancer Research.
Both Doctors Lowy and Dr. Schiller have been inducted as
fellows of the AACR Academy and are elected members of the National
Academy of Sciences.
Through decades of visionary science, collaboration, and commitment
to global health, Doctors Lowy and Schiller have fundamentally
transformed prevention. Please join me in
welcoming the 2026 recipients of the Pescola
Foundation AACR International Award for Extraordinary Achievement in
Cancer Research, Doctors Douglas R.
Lowy and John T. Schiller. Thank you.
Doug, the stage is yours.
Well, good afternoon, everyone.
My next slide actually is the most important one.
I really first want to thank the Pescola
Foundation
For their incredible strong support
for many aspects of cancer research, and
especially because John and I are receiving this award
for highlighting the importance of basic cancer research
to progress in our field.
I also want to thank Dr. Yokers for
not deducting points from John and me just
because our research went beyond basic research.
We are very excited to be here and to tell
you some of our story about our journey
through cancer research from basic research,
translational, and
most recently, clinical.
So my disclosure slide, very important.
NIH has patents on the virus-like particle vaccine
technology, and John and I are inventors.
NIH has licensed the technology to Merck and
GlaxoSmithKline, the two companies with FDA-approved
versions of the vaccine. Importantly, I will
discuss non-FDA approved intervention, single-dose
HPV vaccination. And then at the end of his presentation,
John will discuss his collaborative research with Ora
Biosciences, where he has intellectual property.
My part of the presentation will focus on vaccine development
characteristics and impact, and John will focus on the
biological basis of HPV vaccine protection.
First, why are we here? It's really the
epidemiology of HPV-associated cancer.
There are many oncogenic viruses.
They account together for about 1.4 million cancers or
8% of worldwide cancers, and three of those
viruses account for about 90% of those cancers,
with HPV predominating. Two
important bullet points. First, cervical cancer accounts for
more than 80% of these worldwide cancers.
And second, more than 10 oncogenic HPV
types account for these
cancers, of which HPV 16 is the most
oncogenic.
This slide tells you really that
women who get cervical cancer come from
low-resource settings. What I've done here
is in the first column to give the countries, second
column,
the
cancer incidence of cervical cancer, mortality rates, percent
mortality rate, and relative GDP per capita.
What I hope you can appreciate, using Mozambique as a
GDP per capita of one, the United States per capita
is more than 50 times as high. Portugal has
a similar mortality rate, and actually a quite
similar mortality to the
United States, 30% mortality rate.
But as you go to the less
intensive resource countries, Brazil, Angola, and
Mozambique, the
incidence of mortality goes up 50%,
66%, 77%, and the
number of people dying per 100,000 also
goes up.
So what is the HPV vaccine? It's a preventive
vaccine for precision primary cancer
prevention. It's a subunit vaccine, targets the prevention
of infection and disease by the oncogenic agent.
And for the purpose of this talk, this was John and
my first translational research.
It was really the freedom of the NCI Intramural Research
Program that was essential to our success.
And Reinhard Kernbauer, who at that time was a postdoctoral
fellow in our lab, really established the
paradigm by which the L1 vaccine
is made. We did it in
insect cells, where he inserted the L1 gene, there were two
structural viral proteins, L1 being the main one, into
a baculovirus expression vector and produced recombinant virus
in insect cells. It spontaneously assembled into 360
copies of L1 into a virus like particle.
Importantly, the VLPs induce high titer
virion-neutralizing antibodies, and they are
non-infectious and non-oncogenic.
In addition to that,
we developed several widely used assays for measuring the
antibody responses to the vaccine, both the lysovax
antibody assays and neutralization assays, which are
considered by the WHO the gold standard
assays. We also showed the vaccines were highly protective
in two animal papillomavirus models, in rabbit
papillomavirus and bovine papillomavirus.
And we predicted a multivalent vaccine would be needed for the
widest protection. And in addition, an early phase
randomized controlled clinical trial, we showed the vaccine was
highly immunogenic and well-tolerated both in young adult men
and women.
This slide,
on the one hand, verified our predictions, and on the
other hand, was simply an extraordinary result.
This was a monovalent HPV 16
vaccine that was reported now more than 20 years ago
by Laura Koutsky and her colleagues.
This is the analysis of women fully vaccinated with, at that time,
three doses of HPV 16 VLPs, who remained
DNA negative throughout the vaccination period.
First look at the HPV 16
DNA persistentThere were
41 cases of persistent HPV16 infection.
All 41 were present in the placebo
group, zero in the control group. This,
needless to say, was really even better than we
had hoped for. Transient infections were also important
because they showed that the transient infections
were about 75% of the women in the trial
never got infected.
The persistent infection or two consecutive
assays for HPV16. So
the vaccine provides sterilizing
immunity in most patients. In addition, when you look
at cervical dysplasia,
shown
here in the green rectangle, as you would expect,
no cases of HPV16. But when you look at other
cases, there was a similar percentage or number of
cases in the placebo and the VLP group, which really
fulfilled our prophecy that you would need a multivalent
vaccine. Fast-forward to today, there are three
FDA-approved vaccines. Cervarix made by
GlaxoSmithKline and Gardasil, the two first-generation
vaccines, both of whose
anti-cancer are HPV16 and
18. And then the second
generation, Gardasil 9, made by Merck, that in addition
to targeting HPV16 and 18, targets the next
five most common HPV types
responsible for cervical cancer.
And Gardasil 9 is the only HPV vaccine currently sold in the
United States.
This shows you the profile of
HPV-associated cancers in the United States, viewed from the
CDC perspective. In dark blue are
shown the percentage of these different kinds of
cancers that can be prevented by
HPV16 and 18, the first-generation vaccines.
In the lighter blue, the additional number of cancers prevented
by the second generation, Gardasil 9, and in the
white are the number of cancers for
each type that are not prevented by
the vaccine. Note that with
cancer of the oropharynx, there actually are
more cases of HPV
oropharyngeal infections and cancer compared to
cervical cases in the United States, thanks to Pap smear screening
and
follow-up. What about safety? Very important if
you're going to be giving a vaccine to an otherwise normal
population. And the answer is both with the
Gardasil and Gardasil 9, there have been no
showstoppers. The safety record has been shown to be
very good. Protection conferred by the commercial vaccines.
First,
as you saw with the HPV16 monovalent trial,
the vaccine has very high efficacy.
Not shown, long duration of protection, which I and
John will come back to. Second, as you saw, vaccine
confers sterilizing infection...
I'm sorry, sterilizing immunity prevents infection in most vaccinees.
Third, it induces herd protection even with
suboptimal vaccine uptake. We estimate about
50%.
Fourth, the vaccine does not treat established infection.
What about cervical cancer? This is from a trial published now
five years ago from Denmark using real-world
evidence, showed about a 90% protection
for young women, women under 30,
who had been vaccinated when they were 16 years old or younger.
And this is shown here in the red are the vaccinated women, and
these are the non-vaccinated women.
If you go over to the right side, you can see women who
were vaccinated by 20 to 30 years of age
did not have the same kind of protection because
most women,
soon after they
engage in sexual activity,
they acquire HPV infection that ultimately
leads to cancer. And the women vaccinated 17 to 19 years
old were in between. And similar results have been
reported in several other countries. What about in the United States?
Although vaccine hesitancy has been an important
consequence of the COVID pandemic, it has
not yet really applied itself to the
HPV vaccine. What I'm showing here is that in
2019, 72% of teenagers
13 to 17, both boys and girls, had at
least one dose. If you fast-forward to five years later, the most
recent time that we have data,
it has gone up to 78%. And
between 2019 and '24, the percentage of adolescents who were
up to date, that is two doses if they were 14
or younger, or three doses if they were 15 or older,
75% in '19, going up to 80% in
'24. So now, what might
the nonprofit sector be able to contribute to an
FDA-approved vaccines? The cynics in the audience will say,
"Not much."
I am here to tell you that we actually can contribute a certain amount.
BasicallyThe vaccine's mechanism of action, as John will
describe, and this includes developing a mouse
HPV challenge model. Clinically, a long-term
collaboration with our NCI intramural epidemiologic
colleagues. First, in our initial trial, we showed
that high protection, both in the oral cavity and the anal canal,
and as I'll tell you briefly, high protection from single
vaccine dose. This is a dose de-escalation study.
Our first indications were now
more than 10 years ago when we found
that the antibody levels
were essentially flat by the time you got to six months
to 48 months after vaccination.
As John will explain, this is really unheard of for a
subunit vaccine, and it's substantially higher than the
antibody levels after natural infection.
This led us to hypothesize that even a single
dose might be sufficient to give high
protection against HPV vaccination.
To go along with this, two years earlier, Aimee Kramer,
and us, and many others had shown
that in this trial, one, two, or
three doses made no difference in the degree of
protection. And basically, all of the women who got just one dose
had no infection.
This led us to hypothesize that
we needed a really big trial
to demonstrate unequivocally that one dose would not
be inferior to two doses. And so
Aimee and
our Costa Rican colleague, Carolina Porras, were the principal
investigators for this ESCUDO trial, where we
compared two doses
and one dose for two FDA-approved
vaccines, Gardasil 9 and Cervarix.
These are an abbreviated version of the data looking at
vaccine efficacy. This is five-year HPV
16/18 results, show similar high
efficacy for one or two doses, basically
97% or 98% efficacy, and
down on the bottom I've also noted the trial met its goal to demonstrate
one-dose efficacy is not inferior to two
doses. I'm sure many of you will be interested for more
information about the single vaccine research, and I
urge you to attend Aimee Kramer's presentation
on Tuesday morning.
And the title of her presentation is "Single-dose
HPV vaccination: a shot in the arm for cancer prevention" in a
session on vaccination and self-sampling for cervical cancer
prevention and early detection.
And
they're going to be important
by Carmen Guerra and Jane
Alegre about this with a
recent FDA approval. I urge you to come.
Let me summarize my part before I turn you over
to my younger and smarter brother.
Even with single vaccine dose, the HPV
vaccine induces long-term protection against the HPV types in the
vaccine, but it does not treat established infection.
Second, in women, the vaccine prevents both
infection and disease. Most vaccines work mainly by preventing
disease rather than also protecting infection.
Third, the vaccine induces herd protection even at
sub-optimal vaccine uptake. And fourth, the vaccine
global uptake continues to increase, accelerated by
single-dose. Currently in 162 countries, of
which 92 use single-dose vaccination.
Thus far, it's estimated the vaccine has prevented
1.4 million future deaths with potential to prevent
millions more.
Now John will take over and tell you about the secret sauce.
So first of all, I'd like to thank Doug for almost staying on time.
Now, many of you don't know that, but Doug was actually my postdoctoral
mentor, and that's why I always let him go first.
Now, I hope that Doug has convinced you that the HPV is a pretty
remarkable vaccine.
And what I'm going to be addressing is essentially the biology to answer two
questions. First, why is it the only vaccine
against sexually transmitted disease that's ever been successfully
developed? And second, why is it the only subunit
vaccine that's ever been successfully developed to be used as a
single dose?
And so like most things in biology, it's complicated.
There are multiple factors involved.
But for the HPV, it really gets down to three things.
One, the vaccines
are exceptionally good at inducing neutralizing antibodies.
Second, we figured out that the way the virus infects makes it
exceptionally susceptible to those antibodies.
And the third is the basic biology that these have
slowly mutating DNA genomes so that the
neutralizing epitopes on the variant surface aren't evolving
rapidly in response to the vaccine, as they are for
RNA viruses like HIV or
hepatitis C.
So let's start with the immunological considerations.
So I think as most of you know that neutralizing antibodies is really the key for
preventative vaccines, and that's true for the HPV vaccine as
well.Over 98% of subjects
generate a readily detectable antibody response to
this vaccine, and that's true even after a single dose.
So how long do the antibody responses last?
Doug previewed this. Well, first of all, if you look at the normal
response to a systemic virus infection,
what you see is that there's a peak, and then there's short-lived
plasmablasts that die out as the virus is cleared.
And then you get this
plateau of long-lived plasma cells that reside in the bone
marrow and pump out antibodies essentially the rest of your life
without exposure to new antigen.
Now, most vaccines, most subunit vaccines and nucleic acid
vaccines, you don't reach this plateau. They continue to fall.
And so you're not generating a large number of long-lived plasma
cells.
So if you look at this, what does this look like?
Does it look like a virus infection or does it look like a subunit
vaccines? It looks like a virus infection.
And this shows data out to five years, and now we have data
out to 16 years that the antibodies are essentially flat,
changing by about 2.5%
per year
later on.
So for the immunological conclusion, a single priming dose of the
HPV vaccine consistently induces high quality and durable
antibody responses, presumably by the induction of long-lived
antibody responses.
So how does this do that? Why do they make such potent antibody responses?
And we think it's all have to do with structure.
And it's quite ironic that at the time we initially developed these VLPs, and
we did this so we could generate good conformational dependent epitopes
on the surface. There was this paper that came out from
Bachmann and Zinkernagel that hypothesized that B cells
specifically recognize antigens with repetitive
epitope spacing of 50 to 100 angstroms. And why did they think that?
It's because this spacing is unique to microbial
surfaces like the outer shell of a virus or bacterial pili,
and protein complexes of this spacing are just not
seen on the vertebrate animal surfaces that are exposed to
systemic immunity. And so I like to think of the B cell receptors
as essentially have being evolved as an antigen-specific
pattern recognition receptor.
So what we think is happening here is that when these multivalent
antigens interact with the B cell receptors on the surface of cells,
it forms a oligomerization of the downstream signaling
molecules,
an exclusion of inhibitory molecules that send very strong
signals to generate high antibody responses that last a
long time, as opposed to monomeric antigens, which are the type that are
normally floating around in our body, which tend to induce low
antibody levels of short duration.
So now let's turn into the virology.
And I really think that, and we didn't know any of this initially, the
virologic features of how this virus infects has as much to do with this
success as does the ability to induce such high
levels of antibodies. So we developed a mouse cervical
vaginal challenge, based upon some what we call HPV
pseudoviruses, where they encapsidate a marker plasmid rather than
the genome. And what we found is that this process is
remarkably slow, the slowest process for any virus that we've
ever seen. And so surprisingly, when we infected the
vaginal tract, the virus didn't bind anything.
Okay? It didn't bind
the cervical squamous or even columnar epithelial
cells. But if we traumatized the epithelium, it
very avidly bound the basement membrane.
And what we found is what it's binding on the basement membrane is heparan sulfate
proteoglycans. But they have specific modifications
which aren't found on the surface of epithelial cells or actually
any other cells that we've tested in the body.
They have a lot of HSPGs, but they don't have the specific modifications
that are required for binding. And this binding induces a series of
conformational changes, quite complex, that eventually
exposes a receptor surface on the
virus that can now bind the cell surface receptor.
And again, it's such a slow process, and so it allows for a long time for these
antibodies to collect and prevent infection.
And the other thing it does is it provides a more efficient way for the
antibodies to get to the site of infection.
Initially, we thought that this vaccine could potentially work because there
is a substantial amount of transudation of IgG
through the neonatal Fc receptor in the vaginal tract,
more than in most mucosal surfaces.
But when we looked in the cervical vaginal mucosa of
vaccinated women, what we found is that the levels were about 10 times
lower
through most of the cycle than they were in the serum.
And at the time of ovulation, the vaccine-specific antibodies and all
antibodies dropped another tenfold.
So we were concerned that these lower level of antibodies wouldn't be sufficient to
produce long-term protection from infection, which in fact what the
vaccine does.
But then when you think about that it has to infect from a wounded
site, this allows direct exudation of interstitial
antibodies that are also going to ooze out at the site of wounding.
And it's been recently shown, quite surprisingly, that interstitial antibody
levels are similar to those in blood.
So by the time the virus reaches its binding site on the basement membrane,
it's actually
exposed to virtually the same antibodies as if it would be
circulating in the blood.
So one of the things we asked then is how much antibody is needed for
protection?
And we couldn't do this in the clinical trials because there are so few
breakthrough infections, and there's no immune correlates with
breakthroughs.And so we turned to our mouse model, and we
asked, are the plateau levels after vaccination near
the minimum needed for protection?
And will the four-fold difference, I forgot to mention this, there's only a four to
two-fold difference between three doses and one dose
if you go out to 10 or 15 years.
And so what we did is we did a classic passive transfer experiment where
we vaccinated a rabbit, in this case, three times
with our VLPs, and then we diluted the serum
and transferred it into a naive mouse that hadn't been
vaccinated and then challenged that animal
intravaginally with HPV pseudoviruses that express luciferase.
And so if you get signal, you're getting infections. If you don't, you don't.
And so what we found is that you could actually dilute the sera that would be
circulating in that mouse, could be 10,000-fold lower than what was
circulating in that rabbit and still get strong protection, which is
totally amazing. And then so we asked the question, well, what's the
mechanism of
infection inhibition if you have what we call a high dose, which is only
100-fold dilution versus a low dose?
And what we found is that at a high dose, it's basically happening like you see in
an in vitro neutralization assay, where the
virus, it gets coated with antibodies and can't interact with these
HSPGs. But surprisingly, at low dose, what we
see is that we actually see basement membrane binding.
We see evidence of this conformational change, but we never see the
virus to be stably associated with the cell surface.
Instead, we see it predominantly attached to monocytes
and neutrophils. So we think that these
relatively low levels of antibodies serve as handlebars for
phagocytosis by the neutrophils
and/or there's possible that it could be causing degranulation after they
bind the cells.
So explanations for the high potency of VLP vaccines.
We think, again, there are two critical factors.
First of all, structure, structure, structure.
The dense repetitive display of neutralizing epitopes on the
surface of the VLPs makes them exceptional inducers of high
titer and durable antibody responses.
And then it's the mechanism of HPV infection.
This is why other STD vaccines don't work.
They don't have
the ability to be neutralized by such low levels of antibodies.
The remarkable slow infection process in vivo,
with an obligate initiation at an acellular
site, it's the only virus that initiates infection at an acellular site,
makes the virus exceptionally susceptible to inhibition by low levels of
antibodies.
And so now in the last few minutes, I'm just going to turn to tell you
that the VLPs can do more than prevent HPV infection.
We think that they can actually become guided missiles to be
used in therapy. This is an example of where if you do some
basic research, you may find something interesting that has
translational implication. And what we found, again, surprisingly,
is I told you that the virus normally binds specially modified
forms of HSPGs and the basement membrane.
Well, it turns out that almost all cancer cells develop the same
type of modifications.
Okay? And
so what this does is, again, we can think about the VLPs
as a platform to serve as a guided missile to treat
cancer. And so a company, Oro Bioscience, started up by
Eli de los Pinos, the CEO, to exploit this
technology. And we've worked together for more than 10 years where we do most of
the preclinical work in our laboratory, and the company does what
companies do best, GMP production and clinical trials.
And just to convince you that these tend to bind cancers pretty well and
diversely, this is a panel of 129 cell lines we looked at
for binding, and almost all bind reasonably well
and are infected
by HPV pseudoviruses. The one exception is hematopoietic
cells, which are known to be low in HSPGs.
And so we're asked the question, well, it's kind of weird.
Why do all these cancers develop these HSPG modifications?
And so we looked at the screen, we screened the
RNA-seq data from these cell lines and asked what correlates with
binding.
And it turns out what stood out more than anything else is EMT
transition, epithelial to mesenchymal transition,
and that at least in our epithelial lines we looked at is driven by
TGF-beta.
And so what we think is happening is that these HSPG
modifications are involved in signaling that allow
dedifferentiation of cells. So when we get this EMT transition,
they don't go all the way from going from epithelial cells to fibroblasts, they
stop in the middle in an undifferentiated state.
And we think that one of the main signaling mechanisms we've stumbled upon is
these HSPG
alterations that are responsible for that.
So then the question was, well, what kind of cytotoxic payload should
we deliver?
And we ended up doing something by making a
conjugate with something called IR700, which is a dye
that's activated
by infrared light. We can get about 200 of these
molecules linked to the virus-like particles.
And what's great about this is it's got dual specificity because it only
kills when the particles are bound
to the membrane, and it only kills when you shine the
light. So there's basically no off-target
killing by this drug.
OopsAnd
it also, we found out, has a dual mechanism of activity.
One is we get this direct cytotoxicity, and within minutes these
cells die because you poke these holes in the membrane due to ROS production and
maybe mechanical stress.
And then
in addition to this direct necrotic type of death,
this releases neoantigens and
danger-associated molecular patterns, which then activate
neoantigen T cells, and we get secondary T cell responses.
So,
one of the problems with this technology is because it's going to be used for so
many different cancer types, what do you start with?
And we started to go with kind of an orphan disease, which was
small ocular melanomas, which form in the choroid space.
And we initially did a Phase 1/2 trial where we injected it
intravitreously.
And that worked
reasonably well except that there was some vitritis.
And you can imagine that that's got quite a large volume and so the drug
was diluted. Then in the second set of trials, we actually did
suprachoroidal right into the choroidal space so it can diffuse
into the tumor, and then we shined the light on it.
And we found no vitreous there. And so we decided to do a Phase III trial
with suprachoroidal injection, and it's well underway.
It should probably read out
in a year, and it's only in about 100 patients.
And the primary endpoint is both preservation of vision, and so far in the
Phase II trials, we've had excellent
preservation of vision, and
also the delay to referral to standard of care
versus no treatment, because these are small tumors and generally are followed by
watchful waiting, but it often ends up that these metastasize before
they're treated.
I just keep hitting the wrong button.
So this just shows the data from the Phase II trial, where there was no placebo
control, but we compared what happened when we were doing the dose escalation,
where there were actually subtherapeutic doses to what we now are using as
a therapeutic dose in the clinical trials, which is
three cycles of three weekly injections.
And as you can see that the time to referral to standard of care
is much greater in the therapeutic dose.
And if you look at these tumors that are actively growing at the time of
treating with the therapeutic dose,
you can see that they basically stop growing.
So the second
cancer that we're going for now is non-muscle
invasive bladder cancer, and that's in a Phase 1/2
trial where we do local administration and light activation via
a standard cystoscope. And I can tell you, the data's not been
published, but it's been discussed, that in a study that was
a window of opportunity where we would treat the
patient
and then two or three weeks later
it would be taken out by standard surgery, there was no tumor left.
Okay? So we're very optimistic that this is going to be also a successful
treatment for bladder cancer.
Okay. So thanks to our many collaborators. We talked about a few here.
I don't have time to do it all, but obviously Doug and I don't do it.
And thanks a lot for your attention and for
being here today.